-We're about to play a game
called "What's Behind Me?"
My partner tonight is the host
of the Emmy-nominated
"The Drew Barrymore Show."
And she has a new cookbook out
right now
called "Rebel Homemaker:
Food, Family, Life,"
available November 2nd.
Please give it up for the
one and only Drew Barrymore!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Ah, I love you,
love you, love you.
-Oh! Thank you!
-All right, Drew.
Here's how the game works.
Drew and I will take turns
facing our backs to the curtain.
Behind the curtain
will be something
neither of us have seen before.
It could be people. Could be
objects. Could be anything.
Once the curtain opens,
you have to pick up your card
and you have 45 seconds
to try to get the other person
to guess what's behind them.
You can say anything you want
or use gestures.
You just can't say any
of the words on your card.
Drew, you'll be guessing first.
Let's get into position.
-Whew. Oh, my gosh.
[ Laughs ]
I wasn't expecting that.
I'm not kidding. I didn't know
it was gonna spin.
-Yeah, me neither. Oh, yeah.
All right. Face me.
So that there's nothing --
you can't see.
Now let's -- [ Clears throat ]
Let's open the curtain
and see what's behind you.
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughs ]
Okay. Okay.
[ Laughter ]
Okay. A very famous painter.
-Picasso. Monet.
-On PBS.
-Oh, Bob Ross.
-[ Ding ]
-Yes.
Now, he is painting
a -- a man who --
He used to hold his hand
in his jacket like this.
French.
-Is this a character
or real-life person?
-Historical figure.
-Yes.
-Napoleon?
-Okay. God.
-And then that gentleman
is doing a new type of exercise,
kind of.
-Like a TRX?
-Yes, close.
They do it around Central Park.
They do it wherever you have
pipes and things
you can hang on.
-Parkour.
-Yes, yes! That's right.
Bob Ross painting
Napoleon doing parkour.
-[ Dinging ]
-All right! All right!
-Can you spin? Can we see?
Then you -- Look at this.
Fanta--
♪♪
-By the way, that was so fun!
[ Laughter ]
-Here we go. It's my turn.
So let's rotate.
It's my turn to guess.
Here we go.
-Was that Will Ferrell?
-Yeah.
That was Will.
That was Will Ferrell.
-I love your glasses, Questlove.
They're awesome. It's the green.
I love color,
and I make makeup and eyewear,
and so I'm always looking at
the, like, opacity and tonality.
-Of course. That's right.
By the way, what is your --
the Beautiful line?
-Oh, that I'm leaning all in on.
And it's -- There's a chapter in
there about me developing it.
-Did you see this?
This is like --
Dude, you're making,
like, all cool-looking --
-That's where I'm headed.
-Fryers and coffee pots.
-Beautiful.
-Life in the last few years
changed all of us.
So I wanted to come up
with a more less schmatta,
more living solutions-based,
like, strategy
for things
that I wanted to make.
And I love designing,
and I'm obsessed
with the things
that are forced to be out --
garbage cans
and, you know, air fryers.
-Coffee pots.
-The things that are out
that we're not putting away.
-You can move the chair.
You can spin the chair.
-And so I wanted to take
a soft future approach...
-I can't hear you.
-...and create
a technologically driven line.
-I can't hear.
All right. I can't hear a thing.
Let's spin back. Beautiful.
-And create color waves
that I don't see
out there in the marketplace,
and it's driven me to become
more of an inventor
than, you know, wanting
to make another throw pillow.
Because I just think, like,
our priorities changed,
and so now I want to innovate
rather than just design.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And this was the most fulfilling
endeavor I've ever been on.
-Well, now it's time for another
fulfilling endeavor.
I'm going to try to guess
what's behind me.
-This is so fun
because we just played,
like, all those games recently,
and I'm all juiced up.
-All right. Here we go.
Let's grab that blue card and
then let's open the curtains.
And time starts
when you start talking.
-Olive Oyl's husband
in the cartoon was...?
-Popeye.
-There we go.
And, oh, it's late at night.
My bones are hurting.
I need a...
-Massage.
-Thank you.
And Scottie Pippen's
partner was...
-Michael Jordan.
-There you go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Dinging ]
♪♪
-Wow! That's fantastic!
Hi, Mike.
Good to see you, buddy.
-Mike looks like
he needs a massage.
-Yeah, he's still wearing
his Bulls uniform.
-Yeah.
-That's the way --
He likes to get recognized,
you know.
-Yeah. And Popeye is still
in his garb, too.
-Yeah, and still smoking
all these years.
-I know. A corn-cob pipe.
-I think he's vaping
these days.
-Yeah. [ Laughs ]
-Okay. It is your turn to guess.
Let's rotate this moving thing.
Our whole budget went to this.
♪♪
That was kind of a fun move.
Our whole budget went
to this rotating stage.
-A turn on the turn,
and then we vomit.
-This is the new format
of "The Tonight Show."
I interview you like this.
Every question --
I ask you a question,
they rotate,
and then you answer.
Okay, let's see
what is behind you, bud.
[ Clears throat ]
-I'm very excited.
-Oh! I love these.
I love these -- this group.
Uh, British...
[ Laughs ]
British superstar.
-Elton John? Radiohead.
-A group.
-Beatles. Rolling Stones.
-I can't say their gender,
but they're not boys.
-Spice Girls?
-Yeas, correct. Spice Girls.
They are standing
in where you were just
with this miracle witness.
-Pumpkin patch?!
-Yes!
And they're drinking
what holiday beverage?
-Eggnog?
-Not quite that holiday.
What holiday are we in now
kind of?
-Pumpkin spice latte?
-That's correct!
-Aah!
-Oh, my gosh!
[ Dinging ]
♪♪
Look at -- The Spice Girls!
-Oh, my God.
-They're drinking pumpkin spice
lattes in a pumpkin patch!
[British accent] I love you.
I know. I know you're scary.
I know.
-Yeah, you are.
-I saw that. Very nice.
-How great is it that you say,
like, Beatles, Rolling Stones.
No, the girls. The Spice --
They're not men. Spice Girls.
-Not men, and you go,
first thing, "Spice Girls."
They're big. They're powerful.
Yeah.
-Congratulations, ladies.
-All right.
It's time for our final round.
-Yes!
-Let's rotate.
♪♪
All right. Here we go.
All right.
Now let's see what's behind me.
Here we go.
[ Clears throat ]
-This is amazing. Okay.
Uh, she -- Oh, gosh. Okay.
Every reference I m--
Um, Harry and William's
grandmother.
-The Queen.
-Yes.
-Her Majesty.
[ Ding ]
"Nightmare on Elm Street" star.
-Freddy Krueger.
-Thank you.
And Leo on the bow of...
-Oh, okay.
-So it's Freddy Krueger and the
Queen on the end of "Titanic."
-By the way, maybe I should
have looked at my card.
Right? Drawing them?
Holding?
Oh, hi! Your Majesty.
It's so great to see them.
Oh, my goodness.
That is so scary.
You look very beautiful,
but they look very frightening.
Thank you very much.
Good to see you guys.
-Thank you! Thank you so much.
I think I got a little
too swept up in...
-Yeah, you got swept up
in the romance of it all.
-I did.
-Drew Barrymore, everybody!